era bom tarrafa e aí galera que assiste
o meu canal do povo você olha que meu
célula a carregando sob a tomar essa ou
ela devia velha seja dia 10 de junho
fechou em campo grande dia 11 de junho o
show e chorava de dor de junho choe ao
seguir para demorar os próximos dois
meses de shows vai aparecer na tela por
cinco segundo em sociedade tiver essa
cidade que a sociedade tiver a sociedade
ou se a sua cidade estiver entre elas só
entram site que vai aparecer em baixo da
data aplica no primeiro tempo na
descrição do vídeo que você vai comprar
um grande
e se eu parei para a segunda colocada
sai da escola ele não quer mais saber de
escola não só de vez em quando bate uma
saudade mas na escola que a saudade e da
escola não me acordar bem cedinho e
estudar de manhã que o coisa que eu não
entendo porque é que o que a pessoa
coloca criança para estudar de manhã
pode noite estuda de manhã para o descem
tudim amy acordado pedim o game que o
rick acorda chega sempre do lado e não
haja acordo feito na escola o mãe tô com
tanto sono muito faz 50 mãe coloca mesa
pra gente tomar café e 9 mais um
pouquinho itajaí acordar na mão do pobre
acorda
olha só três vezes ela disse que embora
vão embora vão embora se não for eu fico
rico levanta que acreditar nisso
antofagasta e debata banco vá no pé sim
mas o pobre do elevador que acabou na
cama está aqui joaquim 2222 a camisa do
candidato a vereador de 2001 da casa do
ano aqui o que ele usa para tudo para
dormir para jogar bola lavar a louça é o
filho do rico vai tomar café tá na mesa
que chegue por mamão melão com presunto
queijo tapioca e august é o pobre tomar
café tá lá a mesa limpa ele fosse passar
um macaco ele não mexe em nada aí lá não
tinha uma pena porque na quina da mesa
tem quatro creme crack e um copo
encontrei de café é escrever crack em
café e é se quiser agora como não chamar
recheio do colégio fica olhando o lanche
do sobrinho do pobre pede só que ele
disse e me dá ele fica descrevendo que a
pessoa tá comendo até ela dá um pedaço
com ele acaba comendo coxinha o carro
assim é dono isso é bom né abastece na
gordura é bem gostoso entanto cabeça e
testemunhas e exibem tinto é do de
frango e nunca botou o ocorrido num
petshop bota o ketchup aí no entanto é
do cara bota também muitos não cabe na
boca aberta quando vai derretendo tempo
quando a guerra também mesmo tempo é
dois é bom de mágoa mundial começará
ythaca cumprir meu como tal é meu pai e
mãe dele para coxim matador mordem do
jeito que tá moan e tá do tempo não é
gostoso de mar conta que no início se eu
faço o casal parasse
queria um novo como é com o meu filho
vai de marvel pátria e briga na escola
nessa discussão é que o perfumado e rio
grande foi eu eu eu fui não um fã foi
não foi nenhum eu e one acabei 28 foi
não foi não foi uma rodada onde o pobre
é engraçado que ele pula o idt as
palavras armário é armar mario bros wii
mario bros rosário rosário e foi peguei
não falava tudo obviamente tomou o
número faz com que não viu tocando
cultura e respeito ao rio ave o tarot
eles chegam com a pergunta você pensa
que a pancada vai rolar e ficamos assim
ó fica só rodam sem encostar no vasco a
briga dele pra derrubar não vai ver quem
tonta primeiro ato disse aqui é todo
mundo cada um no seu canto por ela vira
pra trás e começa a conversar sobre o
assunto do rio
botei foi nenhum um medo medo não enviou
a seu amigo dele agora ocupa o rio já
tem uma pessoa que vai buscar ele no
colégio que o pai paga país buscando no
colégio se foi em cidade pequena é um
outro táxi e moto táxi para por mês 11 6
na porta da escola menino do pobre com
as pernas bambas e volta pra casa não
eles vão pra cá só o quinto pequenininho
segurando a bolsa aqui e eles vão em
grupo eo grupo é a mesma pessoa que
brigaram na sala de aula meia hora traz
o bobo e ninguém guarda ressentimento a
caminho do pobre é o seguinte ele volta
pra casa não só reclamando de tudo o sol
quente e 11 6 para meio-dia e rat chan
oitavo a 12 quilômetros de casa e
lembrança e dois quilômetros no sol
suado cansado ele ainda arranja tempo e
disposição para tocar a campanha dos
outros aí corre a menina é um cão parece
que é uma mensagem do pópulo rito manda
carrinho pegar finais quanto vou tocar
na atual campanha vou sair correndo
falar da pool geralmente é um grupo de
cinco eo plano é tocar a campanha e todo
mundo sair correndo isso só pode não dar
certo por dois fatores o primeiro fator
se tiver cachorro e cachorro e tem um
faro especial para menino cachorro tem
ódio de mim a
a tocar a campanha está entre sinal de j
o plano falha é número dois é o seguinte
a gente pára antes de chegar na casa
olha pra todo mundo e combina um pouca e
todo mundo corre agora vai lá todo mundo
preparado pelo que não tava na campanha
em sair com ele há uns 4 passou é para
trás tem fela da [ __ ] andando bem
devagarzinho dizendo assim se perguntar
quem foi à nilo para que o tiram vazio
da infância cathels amigo se traem todo
mundo correndo na primeira esquina que
tem na europa passa não é tudo é dona
chica combinar todo mundo correr atrás e
sabe que move essas coisas negócio de
ficar toca nunca vai sair correndo e
nunca vi que o carro tinha combinado
tinha aceitado horas o que plantar tudo
ficava perdido está em movimento aí
voltaram a arriscar rodada de novo
henrique chegou em casa ela correndo pra
televisão do jeito que tá na escola com
tênis e tudo sobe em cima do sofá e
assistindo lá em casa se subir contentes
em cima do sofá ou morre o pódio
chegando em casa é diferente ele vem
toda animada e mãe olha puxam está
molhado é patrão está tudo só o barro
que ele trouxe os pé e pede menino
surgiu só naqueles cantata a gente olha
para a direita a mãe terno de impacto
vizinho que acaba firewall también de
varzim
[Música]
pega um pano limpo pé e vai voltando
como se tivesse apagando a história dele
ele volte e fingir que chegou de novo a
menina é gênio na do almoço rica maior
frescura pra comer lasanha com meu filho
nem é em abbottabad vai assistir à peça
vai menino pobre pode até dizer na hora
que não vai comer que pode estar
assistindo a mais importante ponto é
cats dragon ball naruto uma barbie e as
três espiãs demais um clube das ruins
nunca se sabe se é importante a criança
agora tem uma frase que a mãe fala que
ela faz qualquer menino sair de onde ele
tiver isso vem comer já vamos assistir
aqui eu guardar água nela você vê
meninas quebra máquina spei correto é
doido se você gosta de se ver você já
sabe é só clicar em gostei aqui no
youtube muita gente a assistir o vídeo
está carregando outro vídeo e outra aba
aí não acabados e já fechou e já fechou
e esquece clicar em gosto então clique
aqui e gostei aqui embaixo vai me ajudar
demais ele pediu pra você me seguindo
meus netos 7 que está aparecendo aqui na
tela e os personagens que eu só faço lá
nuez neto quero que você veja então é
isso aí valeu e b e
[Música]